when the left and right are talking
about impeachment and resignation you
know that the walls are starting to
close in on the president everything
we've spoken about today regarding the
Michael Cohen memo Donald Trump's
failure to convince Mike Pence's chief
of staff to fill in to take the job of
chief of staff John Kelly which we'll
get to a little bit later on in the show
everything that's going on right now
this has led even conservative columnist
to start thinking about Donald Trump's
exit strategy and there is a very
interesting clip from conservative
columnist Jennifer Rubin who was on
MSNBC she laid out what she thinks will
happen if in 2020 or 2024 a Democratic
president wins the presidential election
which is that Donald Trump will resign
ten minutes before Mike Pence does so
that pence can issue a pardon to Donald
Trump so I want to be clear I want to
restate this this is not the hypothesis
of some fringe bleeding-heart liberal
okay I'm talking about Jennifer Rubin
she's a conservative columnist she has
many opinions I disagree with but she
writes for the Washington Post
she's an attorney laborer an employment
lawyer for a long time and the point is
this is a serious person with serious
credentials who is not some kind of bomb
throwing lunatic left or right winger
and here is what she had to say about
this I also don't think that Trump can
pardon himself and if he tries that and
that's his only mechanism he risks being
prosecuted after he leaves office
for that very reason I would predict
here on MSNBC that when Trump leaves
office he will resign the presidency 10
minutes before Mike Pence leaves office
allowing pence to pardon him if there is
not a Republican president to follow him
the one area where Jennifer Rubin may be
wrong or at least under estimating the
strength of that strategy is that there
are possible state crimes here those
don't go away with a presidential pardon
Allah Richard Nixon and this actually
gets to one of the core issues within
the resignation option I've been pretty
steady
fast that if it comes down to it Trump's
not gonna allow himself to be impeached
Donald Trump I have held will resign
before impeachment if it becomes really
clear that he risks being impeached and
he will couch the resignation as it's a
crooked system evil Dems conspired
against me so I couldn't do anything
they put my friends in prison with these
bogus witch hunts and he will sort of
frame himself as a martyr and say that
he's resigning to fight back against the
system that's treating him so unfairly I
mean totally delusional framing but it
would at least allow some possibility of
keeping the support of the trumpet's
base so that part I think is sort of
realistic that Trump would resign rather
than be impeached but the next question
Pat is would Mike Pence pardon Donald
Trump the implication from Jennifer
Rubin is that yes but as much of a
disgusting ideological right-wing or as
Mike Pence is we don't actually know how
beholden he is to Donald Trump he has
been staying out of the limelight Pence
has been almost missing from the
presidency we don't know how compromised
Pence's in the entire thing I think
there are some realistic questions Pat
about whether Mike Pence would be party
to this pardon and resign idea that
Jennifer Rubin is presenting well you
alluded to Richard Nixon earlier a major
reason why Gerald Ford wasn't elected
for a term of his own was because he
pardoned Nixon and I think pence would
look at history and not want to find
himself in the same predicament also
just going along with Jennifer Rubens
theory I don't see why Mike Pence would
need to resign I mean there's nothing
maybe we'll learn more about what's
going on with the whole situation here
but there's nothing directly implicating
him in any of the crimes that we suspect
Trump and his associates of committing
yeah I found that interesting as well
that she mentioned that because that it
has been a question for a while and one
could interpret Mike Pence's total lack
of public visibility as a way to
continue furthering the idea that he
just has nothing to do with any of the
stuff it could also be that pence knows
he's as implicated as Trump but he's not
stupid enough to start tweeting and
attacking journalists and making public
statements so he's doing the sort of
more prudent thing by staying out of it
this is all totally speculative but the
mere fact that some more reasonable
conservative columnist are starting to
argue about how exactly this is going to
happen is pretty telling one of today's
sponsors is privacy calm slash Pakman
this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below